make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so I am in Portland Oregon right
now and I feel like there's gonna be
some fans who were just like how come
you didn't do a fan Meetup
why didn't you tell anybody again I'm
actually on vacation here and and again
like the audio is probably gonna be kind
of crappy it's just really echoing in
here I mean I'm in a hotel room so you
know what all you can you say I don't
have the sound treated space of my home
but in this one we're picking up with
powers of X now this one's kind of
interesting because there is some cool
stuff that happens here but the big take
away is actually one of the
informational pages that Jonathan
Hickman provides in the comic book
itself but one of the things that
focuses on is it focuses on how it is
that we kind of got to the present day
right like Charles Xavier and Magneto
teaming up and working together and
that's one of the cool things is because
when it came to this it's really Hickman
kind of reworking a lot of things
especially when you get to like when you
have x-men Year Zero which is when the
x-men initially formed then you have the
x-men in the modern day and then you
have like the x-men a hundred years from
now and then like like the end of all
things like you know society and like a
thousand years of ten thousand years
whatever it is it's kind of cool to see
this this whole thing played out but
what we saw in house of X was more
McTaggart showing up and basically like
revealing the truth of Charles Xavier
that she had lived all these lives and
she had basically shown him like hey
look this is the future that awaits the
x-men right lay there really does not
seem to be a scenario where like any of
you guys win the only way that seems to
work is where you and Magneto basically
work together because at this point with
these lives as she's lived it doesn't
look like she's experienced a reality
whereby Xavier and Magneto came together
for whatever reason really probably just
the core of their differences and belief
systems it always led to like the
destruction of the x-men presumably
Charles Xavier first and then Magneto or
magneto first and and Xavier whatever
the case happens to be and so because of
that Xavier basically shows up a DAT
Island M which is really more or less
seems kind of be like a precursor to
Genosha and then essentially like
reveals to the truth to them and says
look like in this world that we live in
there doesn't really seem to be a
circumstance whereby our ideologies will
work hand in hand right like we have two
diametrically opposed in views on how it
is that all of even kind needs to be
dealt with in relation to like what's
going on in the world right now but at
the end of the day what Mora McTaggart
showed me is that all of this really
seems to just kind of be going to pot
that if we're going to survive that we
have to work together and that's kind of
the important thing
that Xavier points out here is up for
him it's not about survival really it's
not about like about Charles Xavier zat
survival it's about basically creating a
circumstance whereby the the mutant
population thrives and the mutant
population continues to live on long
beyond the two of them and that's very
far sighted it'd be very easy for him to
kind of sit down and say like I'm
worried about right now right it's what
it's what most people do it's what you
and I do
it's what the average person does
because of that like it's a really
really cool concept when you look at
this and then you kind of apply it to
the nature of mutant kind in the sense
that it's not really about Xavier or
Magneto it is about the survival of
their race and so that's when when
Xavier basically says hey look let me
show you these thoughts that Maura
McTaggart gave me and Magneto allows it
to happen he's basically bombarded by
like all these different scenarios these
scenarios where he's destroyed by
signals be scenarios where he's captured
by shield and held in stasis and so
ultimately it's magneto coming to grips
of the fact that nothing he does matters
and that's a huge revelation to have to
undertake is a huge revelation that
ultimately everything that he does is
for naught that he basically ends up
getting destroyed that it's all just a
giant waste and that's kind of a big
thing it's it's a massive thing right
like imagine if he woke up tomorrow and
you found out that like like you never
amount to anything in your life how
crushing would that be now it's kind of
a really like a really good way to speak
to Magneto's resolve when he basically
says okay fine this is how things are
then yes we'll work together right it's
not it's not rolling over it's not
giving up it's not saying well yeah
whatever I guess it's just the way it
goes it's saying like okay like we have
to work together we have to get this
going and so what it does is it jumps to
your tent jumps to the present day and
you end up having what's called the
mother mold now this is this is an
interesting concept because in Marvel
you had master mold for a long long time
and master mold was basically a sentinel
that created other signals right it was
just it was his great big huge thing you
guys saw next in the animated series but
it was this great great like this huge
robot that probably stood 500 feet tall
and it basically just sat like in this
kind of chair that was built for it and
just pumped out sentinels that's all I
did was just create sentinels and the
result was that it was it was a much
faster and more efficient way of
building them than what was originally
done by Baal of our Trask where it was
just like building them in a giant
Factory and then taking a long time to
assemble and all that kind of good stuff
and so what this is is basically its
mother mold in a sense that it's a
master mold that makes other master
molds and that's kind of a crazy thing
because what this means is that humanity
is rapidly gearing up for
war with mutant kind and that's what
this means that's really the big
takeaway from this moment here is that
when they basically grab this
information with mystique and company
that we saw in house of X grab as
information and brought it to the x-men
it's that exact piece of data that's
going on the basically humanity is
ramping up and stockpiling as many arms
and armament as they possibly can and
that's basically the stance of Xavier is
we have to go here we have to destroy
the mother mold otherwise we're gonna be
painfully outmatched right and it's kind
of a cool thing because this is very
reminiscent of Days of Future past right
I mean it's one of the things we've
talked about in Days of Future past the
reason why the Sentinels were able to
overpower the superhero community so
readily was because there were just so
many of them right I mean if you are
somebody like like magneto and you had
this power of magnetism and suddenly
you'd be met by like a whole fleet in
Armada of like plastic symbols and they
would just completely overwhelm you with
with unrelenting force so instead of it
being like all there's a mutant down
there and here's two or three sentinels
suddenly it's like it's like two or
three hundred sentinels it just they
were maybe like twenty or thirty or
something like that but they all just
descend on you and it's just a war of
attrition right eventually you just get
worn down and that's the nature of these
things that's why that's why signals are
so dangerous is because they don't get
tired they don't wear out right I mean
you can destroy them but like they don't
get exhausted they don't run out of an
energy supply right they're all like
nuclear power their energy can just kind
of go on forever and ever and ever and
so again it's kind of a crazy thing but
from here we jump to the future and we
basically pick up with this piece of
information that was that was gathered
by the forces in the future and there in
turn getting ready to launch their
attack and it's one thing I want you
guys to notice is that this is all about
information information being
transferred from one person to another
right so it's the information that more
and McTaggart has has been given to
Charles Xavier which has now been given
to Magneto and that's how they work
together then it's the information of
you know this governmental
facility that was accessed by the by
mystique and the Brotherhood of Evil
Mutants which was handed over to Cyclops
and Charles Xavier and now you have this
information from the future which is
handed over to none other than
apocalypse and it's kind of crazy
because now this means that apocalypse
is currently running the x-men and it
really kind of begs a question of what
does that mean for the team because of
this is 100 years from now we can
largely assumed that the x-men as we
know them are basically dead right like
Charles Xavier is dead Magneto's dead
they're all dead and gone and it's kind
of a cool thing here because this
information was where they were sent in
there for was a particular bit of
information but the problem was trying
it was like finding a needle in a
haystack
and this huge
log of data that exists out there you
have to go find this one thing and
that's like an impossible feat to
achieve right so what they did instead
instead of them going in there blind and
searching through all these files trying
to find a piece of information they can
steal the codex decipher the codex and
the codex will say it's that way it's
right here it sits in this location and
once they break it down and once they
decipher it then in turn they realize
where this piece of information is and
they have to go in access so the problem
is they have black out of a member of
their group the one who was basically
whisked away she was the one that
basically made them invisible to the
machines and so now they have to go in
there and then be seen and so
essentially they're gonna go into this
place
alarms are gonna be blaring they have to
fight their way in they have to secure
the information and then fight their way
out and as Wolverine says it's a death
sentence but then apocalypse speaks up
and says no I will lead you there and so
what this looks like is this looks like
the precursor for the future that we saw
with more McTaggart were like apocalypse
is obliterated by the forces of humanity
and that's entirely possible here it's
kind of a cool in a crazy little thing
here because then what you do is you
jump to 1,000 years into the future and
you have this kind of whatever this
happens to be whether it's humans or
mutants or what-have-you but basically
like they're met by this giant dark
sphere right that kind of shoots it out
this little black ink or whatever it is
and when it starts to speak to them
which is almost really innocent of the
beyonders for those you guys who read
Hickman's avengers and new avengers when
it starts to speak to them let this
being says is what we're looking for is
ascension and that's when things really
begin to get kind of crazy because what
this does is it breaks down into how
Hickman defined societies and Marvel
Comics based on technology right that's
one of the important things here when he
says you know like societal intelligence
one that's a machine but notice all of
this is tied into a machine is tied into
like robots and and so on and so forth
now this seems to be something that
carries over to like humans like
biological organisms and you probably
could and but with regards to this it's
like a single machine a robot that has
average intelligence right so I think at
this point he's kind of making the
assumption or just kind of going with
the idea of like artificial intelligence
meaning a machine that can think for
itself or the very least maybe something
just like a baseline Sentinel and then
from there you have a hive right so like
a collection of machines all sort of
working together where it's greater than
the sum of its parts and then you have
your your intelligence now intelligence
is cool because this is basically his
way of saying the supreme intelligence
is basically a robot and it's kind of a
cool thing right because the supreme
intelligence really always was the
supreme
colleges was always a robotic source
insofar as it was an organism that was
plugged into the brains of hundreds of
thousands if not millions of the
smartest people to ever exist in the
Kree society and then in turn it can
make decisions accordingly now it is
biological insofar as like there's blood
and there's flesh and different things
like that like it can bleed and so on
but in terms of how it functions it
really is more machine in this sense it
like it's a singular organism that
exists out there and it's an amalgam of
a ton of other minds that it can use for
its own purpose to achieve a particular
goal now from there you move beyond
planetary and then you start getting
into galactic and this is when you get
into things like the tech mark now the
technarch is a really really cool change
by Jonathan Hickman and the reason why
is because this ties directly into the
technarchy and then warlock and Magus
and the reason why is in the 1990s you
had a character by the name of warlock
who was just kind of like this really
crazy-looking guy
in terms of like you know this stuff
sticking out of him and so on and so
forth but the idea behind this was that
it showed up and actually had the
ability to convert any kind of substance
into a technarch like something it could
absorb right and so it was essentially
the son of what was called wolf I guess
I'm being called Magus who was like the
super powerful beam and it was from a
planet always called a catch I don't
know that's really the correct way to
pronounce it and the result was that it
just kind of went forward and then
eventually became a good guy and how I
have the x-man and so on and so forth
and maybe then a lot of it was because
of the fact that like originally in
warlock was like fleeing the the planet
of his father and so on and so forth
what Hickman is doing is coming along
and saying no none of that stuff that
we've seen is what we think it is
instead a warlock and Magus and the
planet ketch and all I kind of stuff
that's one facet of a multitude of
concepts that are called the technarch
basically there's a lot of different
variations of warlock out there there's
a lot of different variations of Magus
out there and they all come from a
planet that's a seemingly called a catch
right so the idea behind this is that
they're not the only ones out there the
reason why we've never seen them is
because no technology a nother
technology it's kind of weird in terms
of like how they were designed and how
they were how they were created but the
idea behind this is they were made for
the purpose of basically going through
and like removing life on planets and
the reason why is because when it comes
to the Phalanx themselves and this is
kind of interesting thing too I want to
talk about that here in a second when it
comes to the Phalanx the way that that
hickman really sort of purports it is
that it's a group of organisms that go
around and essentially deem different
as worthy of being incorporated into
their their group into their collective
if you guys ever watched Star Trek
those who were deemed worthy are
absorbed into it those who are not
deemed worthy are wiped away by the
technology that's the purpose the
technarch serves and the reason why that
matters is because what Hickman says
here is is insane
the Phalanx is an interstellar society
he says a phalanx is an interstellar
society and that wording is particularly
important because what this means is
that it seems as though the Phalanx is
the highest state of intelligence that a
particular organism can achieve a point
which there is no differentiation
between machine and man instead it's
just a super high level of all organism
and the result is that when he says a
phalanx and he made a somebody saying it
for the sake of the explanation and
there really is only one phalanx race
out there or it could be that this is
somebody just a super high level of
achievement right only one group has
achieved the level of phalanx so far but
others can follow if given enough time
and it's kind of a cool thing it is it's
a really really cool concept because
it's a way to sort of take this entire
idea of like like machines intelligence
and so on and so forth and just kind of
roll it all into like this really nice
packaged organized bundle and then send
it off to us as the reader I really dig
it I'm absolutely loving it but when
that being said you guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here - comments explained to make
sure you guys at the sub button to
become part of the robb core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Music]